>>> THIS WEEK PRESIDENT BIDEN
TOOK ON THE BIG LIE AND THE
INSURRECTION.
THE PRESIDENT WARNED THE NATION
IS STILL IN DANGER AFTER THE
EVENTS OF JANUARY 6th.
>> THE ASSAULT ON FREE AND FAIR
ELECTIONS IS JUST SUCH A THREAT,
LITERALLY.
I'VE SAID IT BEFORE.
WE'RE FACING THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT TEST OF OUR
DEMOCRACY SINCE THE CIVIL WAR.
IT'S NOT HYPERBOLE, SINCE THE
CIVIL WAR.
CONFEDERATES BACK THEN NEVER
BREACHED THE CAPITOL.
AS INSURRECTIONS DID ON JANUARY
THE 6th.
I'M NOT SAYING THIS TO ALARM
YOU.
I'M SAYING THIS BECAUSE YOU
SHOULD BE ALARMED.
>> YOU SHOULD BE ALARMED THE
PRESIDENT SAID.
YET THE PRESIDENT DID NOT OFFER
SUPPORT FOR REMOVING THE
LEGISLATIVE BLOCK AID IN
CONGRESS, THE FILIBUSTER, THAT'S
STANDING IN THE WAY OF LAWS THAT
WOULD SAFEGUARD OUR ELECTIONS.
THE PRESIDENT APPEARS TO BE
HOLDING OUT HOPE HE CAN WORK
WITH REPUBLICAN LEADERS, MITCH
McCONNELL AND KEVIN McCARTHY.
MAYBE THAT COULD HAPPEN ON
INFRASTRUCTURE.
BUT A NEW BRIDGE IS NOT GOING TO
PROTECT THE CAPITOL.
IT'S MORE LIKE THE GOP HAS A
BRIDGE TO SELL YOU.
McCARTHY JUST MET WITH THE
INSURRECTIONISTS AND CHIEF
DONALD TRUMP.
APPARENTLY THEY SPOKE ABOUT THE
UPCOMING MIDTERMS OR AS SOME OF
TRUMP'S ALLIES MAY HAVE ON THEIR
CALENDAR, THE NEXT INSURRECTION.
TRUMP IS STILL LYING ABOUT THE
LAST ELECTION.
>> THE MEDIA REFERENCES THE
ELECTION HOAX.
THEY SAY THE FRAUD IS UNPROVEN.
AND WHILE THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE -- NO EVIDENCE?
NO EVIDENCE?
THERE'S SO MUCH EVIDENCE.
>> AND HE'S LYING ABOUT HIS
CROWD ON JANUARY 6th.
>> YOU HAD OVER 1 MILLION PEOPLE
THERE, WHICH THE PRESS DOESN'T
LIKE TO REPORT AT ALL BECAUSE IT
SHOWS TOO MUCH -- TOO MUCH
ACTIVITY, TOO MUCH SPIRIT AND
FAITH AND LOVE.
THERE WAS SUCH LOVE AT THAT
RALLY.
THE CROWD WAS UNBELIEVABLE.
AND I MENTIONED THE WORD LOVE.
THE LOVE -- THE LOVE IN THE AIR
I'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
IT.
>> GIVEN TRUMP'S LOVE FOR LIES
LIKE THAT, DELIVERING A SPEECH
ABOUT SAVING DEMOCRACY WITHOUT
PASSING TOUGH LAWS TO PROTECT
ELECTIONS IS NOT GOING TO BE
ENOUGH.
TO PARAPHRASE THE MOVIE "THE
UNTOUCHABLES" IT'S LIKE BRINGING
A KNIFE TO AN INSURRECTION.
TEXAS STATE HOUSE DEMOCRATS TOOK
ACTION LEAVING AUSTIN FOR
WASHINGTON TO AVOID VOTING FOR A
NEW GOP ELECTION LAW.
ONE OF THOSE DEMOCRATS EVEN WENT
ON FOX TO CALL OUT THE BIG LIE.
>> SO WHAT I'M ASKING YOU TO DO
IS TO TELL YOUR VOTERS RIGHT NOW
THAT DONALD TRUMP --
>> HEY, AT LEAST YOU'VE RESOLVED
THE LIE THAT IS -- AT LEAST YOU
RESOLVED THE LIE --
>> DID YOU CATCH WHAT I JUST
ASKED?
>> IT'S NOT YOUR SHOW, SIR.
>> DID YOU -- DID DONALD TRUMP
LOSE THE ELECTION IN 2020?
>> REAL QUICK --
>> CAN YOU ANSWER THE QUESTION,
DID DONALD TRUMP LOSE THE
ELECTION IN 2020?
>> I DON'T FEEL ANY OBLIGATION.
>> IS THIS AN UNCOMFORTABLE
QUESTION FOR YOU?
>> PERHAPS THE PROP BEGAN DOUSE
ON FOX COULD READ THE NEW TRUMP
BOOKS OUT THIS WEEK.
THE CHAIRMAN OF JOINTS OF CHIEF
GENERAL MARK MILLI WAS CONCERNED
HE WOULD ATTEMPT A COUP, LIKE
ADOLPH HITLER.
THEY MAY TRY TO STAGE A COUP,
BUT THEY'RE NOT GOING TO F'ING
SUCCEED, MILLS WILL EY TOLD HIS
AIDES ACCORDING TO THE BOOK.
MILLEY WILL NOT PUBLICLY ADDRESS
THE ISSUES RAISED IN THE BOOK.
TRUMP DID RESPOND IN A STATEMENT
SAYING IF I WAS GOING TO DO A
COUP, ONE OF THE LAST PEOPLE I
WOULD WANT TO DO IT WITH IS
GENERAL MARK MILLEY.
AS MANY OBSERVED HOW VERY OJ
SIMPSON.
I WAS GOING TO DO A COUP.
SOUNDS LIKE SIMPSON'S BOOK, IF I
DID IT.
CAN SOMEBODY LET US KNOW IF
TRUMP IS SPOTTED IN A WHITE FORD
BRONCO THIS WEEKEND?
ON THE RUN WITH RUDY GIULIANI?
PERHAPS THEY'LL BE HEADING FOR
THE FOUR SEASONS LANDSCAPING
COMPANY.
I CAN JUST HEAR RUDY NOW, IF THE
BOOKS DON'T FIT, YOU MUST
ACQUIT.
BUT I DIGRESS.
ONE OF THE OTHER BOOKS REPORTS
THAT TRUMP ONCE TOLD HIS FORMER
CHIEF OF STAFF, JOHN KELLY,
HITLER, QUOTE, DID A LOT OF GOOD
THINGS.
I'M SORRY.
HOLD ON.
WHEN WE HAVE ENTERED THE REALM
OF COUPS AND HITLER, WE HAVE TO
PAUSE FOR A MOMENT.
THIS IS NOT ONE OF THOSE
SITUATIONS WHERE TRUMP WANTS TO
BOMB HURRICANES OR BUY
GREENLAND.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT COUPS AND
HITLER.
WHY IS KEVIN McCARTHY MEETING
WITH TRUMP WHEN WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT COUPS AND HITLER?
DID HE NOT HEAR PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S WARNING ABOUT AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY?
>> WE'RE FACING THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT TEST OF OUR
DEMOCRACY SINCE THE CIVIL WAR.
IT'S NOT HYPERBOLE, SINCE THE
CIVIL WAR.
>> WHICH TAKES ME BACK TO THE
UNTOUCHABLES.
THERE'S A SCENE IN THAT MOVIE
WHEN SEAN CONNERY PLAYS CHICAGO
POLICE OFFICER JIM MALONE POSES
A KEY QUESTION TO KEVIN COSTNER.
WHAT ARE YOU PREPARED TO DO?
NESS PURSUING THE MOBSTER AL
CAPONE HOLDING HIS MENTOR IN HIS
ARMS MALONE IS DYING AFTER HE IS
GUNNED DOWN BY ONE OF AL
CAPONE'S THUGS.
MALONE'S LAST WORDS ARE -- WHAT
ARE YOU PREPARED TO DO?
LIKE AL CAPONE BEFORE HIM, TRUMP
DOESN'T SEEM TOO CONCERNED ABOUT
HIS PAST CATCHING UP WITH HIM.
IN EXILE NO MORE, THIS
GENERATION'S TEFLON DON APPEARS
TO BE PLOTTING HIS COMEBACK.
AND SOME GOP LEADERS ARE MAKING
THAT HAPPEN.
BREATHING LIFE INTO THE
SMOLDERING RUINS OF HIS
PRESIDENCY.
LAST SUNDAY TRUMP SAID THIS --
>> I DIDN'T BECOME DIFFERENT.
I GOT IMPEACHED TWICE.
I DIDN'T CHANGE.
I BECAME WORSE.
>> I FOR ONE BELIEVE HIM.
HE HAS BECOME WORSE.
IF THAT'S POSSIBLE.
THE CURRENT PRESIDENT SAYS
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY IS STILL
BEING THREATENED.
YES, IT IS BEING THREATENED.
BY THE FORMER GUY.
AS JIM MALONE WOULD ASK, WHAT
ARE YOU PREPARED TO DO?
WHAT IS LAW ENFORCEMENT PREPARED
TO DO ABOUT TRUMP'S ACTIONS
SURROUNDING JANUARY 6th?
WHAT ARE DEMOCRATS PREPARED TO
DO TO PROTECT OUR ELECTIONS?
WHAT ARE YOU, THE VOTER,
PREPARED TO DO TO HOLD
ACCOUNTABLE THOSE POLITICIANS
WHO CHOOSE TRUMP OVER AMERIC